在我的youtube留言區裡,
有很多網友習慣曾稱我為老師,
同時還存在另外一種聲音,
說既然你投資這麼厲害,
為什麼還要辛苦的做視頻寫文章呢?
這兩種說法其實指向了同一個問題,
就是說在我們中文投資圈缺乏一種成熟的、平等的、基於商業邏輯的認知體系。
所以今天我就想來聊聊這個話題
為什麼我不希望你叫我老師
為什麼真正的職業投資者
反而需要做內容輸出
首先我們就先來說老師這個稱謂
老師這個稱謂在中文的語境裡頭
它是一個非常尊貴的詞彙
在2000多年的這種儒家文化的影響之下
我們華人是有尊師重道的這種傳統
那麼老師也有傳道授業解惑
這樣的一個神聖的職責
所以說人們對老師這個稱謂
有著一種天然的敬畏感
那麼潛意識裡面呢
我們認為老師是代表著掌握真理的那一方
但是呢這種文化慣性
如果帶入到金融市場裡面來呢
它就變成了一種致命的認知缺陷
為什麼呢
因為金融市場它的本質是混沌的
是隨機的
在這個市場裡面
根本就不存在所謂的真理
也不存在一個全知全能的絕對的權威
那麼為什麼大家還是熱衷於去尋找
並且稱呼別人為老師呢
那麼我分析下來
主要有三個層面的心理機制
首先就是對不確定性的恐懼
大多數的散戶進入投資市場
面對這種紅綠跳動的數字
感受到的是一種巨大的失控感
這種失控感在心理上是非常痛苦的
所以說叫一聲老師
本質上是在尋求一種心理庇護
這就像是在驚濤駭浪的大海上面
你試圖抓住一塊浮木
你希望這個人告訴你
別怕聽我的
你一定能賺到錢
那這是一種求生欲
也是一種情緒外包
你希望透過確認對方的這種
絕對權威的地位
來消除自己內心的恐懼
其次呢
這是一種認知的懶惰
獨立思考是非常辛苦的
你去研究一家公司的財報
去分析這個宏觀經濟數據
去推演這個政策的影響
這些都是需要消耗大量的腦力
也是需要相當深厚的
專業知識和技能的
那麼相比之下
你去聽一個老師
講一個美妙動聽的故事
然後給你幾個代碼
然後你可以無腦跟單
這顯然要輕鬆的多
這就是一種思維上的一種懶惰的行為
是一種搭便車的行為
那麼更有意思的是
有些網友去別人那裡聽來了一個股票
然後買了
然後被套了
結果跑到我這裡來說
老雷我應該怎麼處理
那我真的是什麼說呢
哭笑不得
第三個呢
就是說叫別人一句老師
其實這是一種
這是什麼呢
責任轉嫁的心態
如果說是你自己做決策
買入一隻股票
結果跌了
你將會面臨巨大的自我懷疑
你會覺得自己很愚蠢
做了一件錯事情
那麼承認自己的錯誤是非常困難的
尤其是這種金錢的損失
你要割捨這些錯誤
是非常非常痛苦的
但是呢
如果說你是跟著某個老師買的
賠了錢
你就可以理直氣壯的去罵他
你是個騙子
你的水平太差
你發現沒有
別小看老師這兩個字
叫一聲老師
其實是你為自己
買了一份心理保險
如果是賺了
那是你跟對了人
你很有眼光
如果是賠了
那是這個老師不行
老師是個騙子
不是你的責任
你是受害者
那麼這樣一來
你的自尊心就得到了
最完美的保護
總而言之
當你稱呼別人為老師的時候
其實你是在主動降格
你預設對方至高無上的地位
或者說是他能夠掌握真理
同時你也放棄了自己
作為一個獨立的投資者
應有的這種批判性思維
那麼這在投資領域
是極其危險的信號
接下來我們來聊第二個問題
也是我經常受到的一種質疑
就是說既然你是職業的投資者
既然你已經財富自由了
那你為什麼還要每天
辛苦的寫文章錄視頻呢
你自己悶聲發大財不好嗎
這種觀點聽上去似乎很有道理
也很有市場
但實際上這是一種非常典型的邏輯謬誤
心理學上被稱之為叫做投射效應
同時也暴露了典型的這種打工者思維模式
什麼是投射效應
簡單來說就是以己奪人
用自己的狀態
用自己腦子裡想的東西
去猜測別人的動機
比如說對於絕大多數
這種朝九晚五的上班族來說
工作是一種為了生存而被迫進行的一種痛苦的交換
在打工者思維模式當中
工作是因為缺錢
如果說我有了錢
那麼我第一件事情就是吵了老闆
停止工作去享受去躺平
所以打工心態的人看到我在做視頻
在寫文章
他就會下意識地推導出
這個傢伙還在工作
說明他沒錢
說明他的投資收益是假的
他是在騙人
他是在割韭菜
然而如果說你站在
資產擁有者的角度上來看
工作的意義就完全不同
你說馬斯克缺錢嗎
你說巴菲特缺錢嗎
為什麼馬斯克還要
這麼有世界首富了
還要沒日沒夜的工作呢
為什麼巴菲特90多歲了
還要每天閱讀幾百頁的報告呢
所以說達到一定財富階段的人來說
或者說財富自由的人來說
他已經自由了
他不需要去為錢而工作
那麼工作已經不再是他的謀生手段的時候
那麼工作就變成了一種自我實現的方式
就比如說我以前
那麼我以前是從事這種藝術設計工作
那種創造出一個作品的這種快感
和我現在構建出一個投資組合
或者說製作出一個高品質的影片
它們產生出來的快感本質上是一樣的
這是我獲得滿足感的一種方式
另外這裡還存在一個
叫做零和博弈的認知偏差
很多人認為賺錢的方法
如果我告訴你了
那麼我就沒得吃了
我就賺不到錢
所以他們認為
真正股市裡的牛人
都應該是藏著掖著的
不會把自己的賺錢的方法說出來
換一個角度說
他們會認為
凡是說出來的方法都是騙人
那麼這種思維方式
或許適用於這種什麼內幕交易
或者說是高頻套利
因為內幕交易和高頻套利
它靠的就是信息不對等
這是它的這個獲利的關鍵
那麼一旦如果說是我把信息告訴來了
公佈出來了
那麼這種就沒有套利空間了
這或許是我認同
你不應該把這種消息說出來
但是對於像我這種
我們是基於宏觀趨勢的投資體系
那麼我分享觀點
甚至我完全公開我所有的交易細節
根本不會稀釋我的獲利
就像我一直在說的這個high five組合
這個組合的每一筆交易都是公開的
交易規則也都是事先明確的
任何人按照這個邏輯
按照這個規則來做投資
都可以獲得同樣的結果
那麼我公佈這個組合
它並不會讓我有任何損失
甚至我認為有更多的人
人參與進來,反而會讓這個
市場的流動性增加
讓這個市場的深度變好
這對所有參與者都是有利的
這是一個多贏的局面,更重要
的是,投資者的護城河
從來不是某一個密集
或者是某一個指標,而是
在於你的性格和執行力,就比如
說,我在很早以前
我就公開說過,如果說
只買一隻股票,我的推薦
是Google,你相信嗎?
你能夠一直持有到今天嗎?
我在2025年4月市場
暴跌過程當中說
牛市在向我們招手
那個時候你會相信嗎
你敢在市場下跌的過程當中
持續買入嗎
所以說我想表達的是
分享這些內容
並不會讓我失去什麼
因為真正的壁壘
是你無法複製我的心態
那麼在打工者思維模式當中
收入是等於時間乘以時薪的
在他們的觀念當中
一旦有了錢
就不應該出賣時間
這是一種打工者思維形態
但是在資產所有者的思維模式裡面
我做YouTube視頻
我寫交易筆記
這不是在打工
這不是在出賣時間
而是在建立我的資產組合
在這個頻道
這些影片
我的幾百篇的交易筆記
這些都是24小時
不間斷為我工作的資產
它能夠為我帶來影響力
能夠為我帶來人脈
甚至可以帶來穩定的現金流
這就是黑天鵝的作者塔勒布所說的
叫做反脆弱結構
投資收益是高波動的
但是這些內容收益
是相對穩定的現金流
用穩定的現金流
去養一個高波動的優質資產
這是一種非常高階的資產配置策略
所以說我在我的
TQQQ長期滾動投資策略當中
我就配置了SGOV和JEPQ
這種配置方式
就是一種反脆弱的結構
那麼感興趣的朋友可以去看看
那麼為什麼說
作為一名職業投資者
反而需要做內容輸出呢
這就要牽涉到一個
叫著名的費曼學習法
我們都知道
投資是一項非常依賴
邏輯推理的活動
那麼我們的大腦中的想法
很多時候是碎片的
是模糊的
有時候呢
我會對某一個投資機會
有感覺
但是呢
如果說這個感覺
不經過整理和深入地去挖掘的話
很有可能這個感覺
就只是一個直覺
然而做視頻或者是寫文章
這是一種強制輸出的過程
為了要把一個觀點講透徹
講清楚
要讓多數的觀眾能夠理解
那我就必須要強迫自己
去查閱更多的資料
去驗證每一個數據的真實性
去推演邏輯鏈鍬當中的每一個細節
去尋找反面的觀點來攻擊我自己
那麼這個過程非常的痛苦
但是也是非常有價值
這就是費曼學習法的精髓
教會別人
其實是最好的學習方式
所以說每當我發佈一個影片
每當我寫完一篇文章
其實我就是完成了一次深度的覆盤
那麼很多時候
正是在我寫稿的過程當中
我理清了自己的邏輯
我發現了自己的這種
某些上面的漏洞
甚至很多時候
它避免了潛在的一些投資風險
所以說某種程度上說
我並不是在教你做什麼
而是我通過對你講述這種方式
來完善我自己的投資體系
來完善我自己的投資邏輯
這是一個利人利己的過程
所以我經常說的一句話就是說
分享者是分享的最大受益者
所以說如果說你希望自己
在投資的道路上走得更遠
走得更高
我認為你應該要儘可能多的輸出
去創作內容
當然不僅僅是投資了
於任何一個行業都是這樣子
說了這麼多
如果說你不叫我老師
那麼我們之間的關係如何定義呢
我建議你把我看作三種角色
第一我們是同行者
我在投資這條路上面摸爬滾打了20多年
你正在經歷的都是我經歷過的
我分享我的經驗教訓
這些都是我的偏見
偏見沒有好壞之分
每個人都在用自己的偏見看世界
重要的是
我的偏見也許能幫助你
看到事物的另外一個方面
第二個呢
就是說我們是平等的交流者
市場之所以存在
就是因為有分歧
我有我的觀點
你有你的觀點
觀點不同是很正常的事情
你不需要贊同我
我也不會為了要你的點贊
要你的贊同來做任何內容
第三個呢
你可以把我看作是你的分析師
我分享了大量的數據資訊
通過我的邏輯加工
然後呈現給你
這些數據訊息邏輯
你都可以拿走
但是呢
我的結論僅供參考
那麼如何看待
我分享這些內容呢
我覺得你要有能力區分
什麼是事實
什麼是觀點
比如說美聯儲
今天宣佈降息25個基點
這是事實
但是如果我說
美聯儲降息將刺激市場上漲
這是觀點
觀點需要被驗證
所以說一個理性的投資者
最重要的技能
我認為應該是
你要有能力把事實和觀點
這兩件事情中間缺失的邏輯鏈條
把它補全
所以我希望大家與我討論邏輯
而不是來問我
現在這個股票能不能買
明天大盤會不會漲之類的
實話告訴你
我不知道
也不會有人知道的
我經常說的一句話叫做
關於未來
沒有人比你知道更多
你需要關注的不是預測
而是邏輯推演的過程
我希望大家來看看我的交易筆記
如果說你做投資是認真的
你會發現其中的價值
好就說這些
下期節目再見